[Musique]
alors que les footballeurs français sont
sourds il ne semble pas qu'ils aient
entendu la marseillaise chantée à pleine
gorge par les vingt mille supporteurs
qui se sont rendus à milan pour les
encourager à centaur d'être sûr mais ce
qu'il n'y a pas de passe d'être aveugle
et maladroit de cette adresse françois
hugues mayot foncé nous en donne un
premier exemple
nous avons des équipes de france face à
une équipe de bulgarie de modeste valeur
pourtant jouent comme des jeunes
débiles gars eux ont une occasion il ne
la bat
ce but réveille un peu la taxe française
qui s'offre cependant un petit festival
de maladresses on occupe le terrain
adverse mais sans trop savoir quoi
on a oublié la marseillaise dans les
tribunes et l'on commence à houspiller
copieusement les joueurs français ce qui
ne les rend pas plus réaliste pour
autant bien au contraire business qui va
nous montrer comment tendanc un but
d'égalisation touffe et voilà la bibli
connaissent en ligne d'envoyer au pic
l'équipe de france n'ira pas au chili et
au fond après un tel match il vaut mieux
s'en féliciter
mitraillages harcèlement mortier c'est
depuis douze jours le lot quotidien
d'elisabeth ville où les troupes
katangaise s'oppose aux assauts des
casques bleus la liste des morts et des
blessés s'allonge à chaque heure
m
l'hôpital prince léopold at-il ou
n'at-il pas été bombardées par l'onu
monsieur de chambé transigera thil et
reverrons-nous un congo uni chier
[Musique]
il est question de résistance mais de
résistance pacifique 800 adversaires des
essais nucléaires ont de nouveau opposé
l'inertie la plus totale aux
responsables de l'ordre et de la
circulation
pour en finir ont décidé d'employer les
méthodes radicales et les policiers
londoniens chargèrent les récalcitrants
dans les cars un par un
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voici le tango bellamy se préparer aux
joies du ski et à celle non moins
excitante de l'après ski chez lola bruce
hack yvette a choisi ce fut la grosse
manche orné de chaînes d'argent martelé
pour marion veracruz tuniques brodées et
plus le rezidor
corinne a préféré se poncho à franges
agrémenté d'une cagoule
marion la chasuble coupe vent sous la
veste bordée de mongolie yvette
emportera cette chasuble tricoter sommet
de cristaux de neige
chez hyacinthe novak isabelle a essayé
mouflon 7 redingote réversible tout rose
doublé de fourrure rose sur une
combinaison de ski rose d'une ligne sans
faiblesse
la ligne est tous dans ses diverses
interprétations de la combinaison de ski
en après-ski gay parce justaucorps de
rési à pompons qui unit à la grâce de
l'hiver la grâce des ballerines
arrêtons jamais vu un après ski du soir
le voici le lan et des belles soirées de
montagne comme en irait-il pas avec
logis
[Musique]
et de novak toujours cette étrange
parures à cagoule souris sourit d'hôtel
ou chauves souris devant laquelle nul ne
se sentira de glace la montagne madame
comme vous l'a rêvé
policier ou espionnage espionnage aux
policiers ils ne meurent pas tous mais
tous en sont frappés en très
naturellement c'est un policier que tous
ces hommes et de toutes les classes lis
ce genre de littérature explique son
énorme production 3 millions de volumes
par mois mais à quoi doit-on la voc d'un
genre hier spécifiquement populaire et
qui conquiert aujourd'hui ses lettres de
noblesse c'est sans doute que pour
l'homme de notre temps la vie à créer
autant de nouvelles servitudes que de
progrès
les horaires les réglementations les
tabous l'atmosphère de termitière
organisé où tout est prévu concertée
défini font de lui le prisonnier de sa
ruche pas de place pour l'imprévu et
laventure dans sept vies contrariées par
des rythme trop rapide
l'homme cerner ne trouve plus d'évasion
il n'a plus l'âge de jouer aux indiens
et dans les rues des villes le ciel est
bien plus haut qu ailleurs à l'heure
le roman qui fait un trou bleu dans la
vie l'évasion à la suite d'un héros avec
lequel on change de visage mais un roman
qui dresse dans un paysage dangereux les
signes évidents de la violence et de la
facilité une évasion à la profondeur des
instincts méprisés par le terrible
quotidien
alors l'homme répond il abandonne sa vie
quotidienne pour deux heures il devient
ce héros prestigieux qui fait la loi et
ne la subit plus il se libère de ses
tracas il s'évade il refait sa vie et
c'est pourquoi espionnage ou policier
policiers ou espionnage il leurs deux
heures d'évasion
[Musique]
cette nuit là pendant une heure ou deux
il y a dans les villes comme un silence
il semble que tout soit arrêté désert
vacants
à peine si un dernier enfant ça raid
solitaire devant les jouets d'une
vitrine est peut-être un clochard
c'est un errant mais un errant de
grandes villes trop exigeants ou fou de
liberté un raté 10 temps aussi où un
flemmard tel quel il fait partie du
paysage nocturne
et cette nuit là sans cafard sans
complexe sans doute parce que c'est dans
nos pays une sorte de besoin le clochard
a suivi des rues
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cher clochard de la grande nuit de
l'année ondres falote qui passe de
vitrine en vitrine de lumière en lumière
tu sais mieux que tout le monde ce qui
flotte d'impalpable dans cette nuit où
personne n'est seul car il ya dans l
autre chose que des charcutaille et
déboute hanche cette espèce de minutes
unique où la vérité existe ou labonté
est à la portée de la main ou la vie
toute vie trouve un sens où la nuit peut
se passer d'aurore
et c'est ainsi de rue en rue de vitrine
en vitrine de lumière en lumière qu'il
finira comme tout le monde mais dans son
univers singulier avec sa tradition de
minuit son réveillon et ses lumières
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pendant que d'autres à la suite du tout
paris et du tout hollywood presque
fêteront noël vidot avec la nouvelle
revue pour vous
[Musique]
j
ouais
ah ah
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]